[Music]
they were an exciting new partnership
for the royal family
connecting in ways that others couldn't
while i'm
here with my husband as a member of the
royal family
i want you to know that for me i am here
with you as a mother
as a wife as a woman
as a woman of color and as your sister
but their dream of a new kind of raw
life wasn't meant to be
incompatible unacceptable and now
they've walked away a spokesperson for
buckingham palace said that the queen
had written
confirming that in stepping away from
the work of the royal family
it's not possible to continue with the
responsibilities and duties
that come with a life of public service
the honorary military appointments
and royal patronages held by the duke
and duchess
will therefore be returned to her
majesty while all are saddened by their
decision
the duke and duchess remain much-loved
members of the family
the tone in the statements were both
very different
buckingham palace statement talks about
being saddened harry and megan are still
much loved members of the family
harry and megan talk about themselves in
their statement and they talk about how
anyone can serve just over a year ago
harry showed he wasn't happy and i know
i haven't always gotten it right
but as far as this goes there really was
no other option
and the reaction this time appears just
as pointed
their spokesperson saying the duke and
duchess of sussex remain committed to
their duty
and service to the uk and around the
world we can
all live a life of service service is
universal
they both lose their official links to
the queen's commonwealth trust and the
association of commonwealth universities
megan will no longer be patron of the
royal national theatre
and harry loses the rugby football union
the rugby football league
and his honorary links to the royal
marines raf huntington
and royal navy small ships and diving
although harry was the most
amazing commander of soldiers and they
all adored him
it's impossible to carry on being the
representative of the queen as head of
state
in a royal capacity which is a very
public role
and at the same time be in commercial
life
on the other side of the world talking
to them in 2019 they seemed excited
about what they wanted to achieve
together
in london la it doesn't matter where you
are we're all sort of
trying to power through and find some
optimism and starting their new life in
the states they've continued to fight
for what matters to them when we vote
our values are put into action and our
voices are heard
what do you think it means now for their
brand now that they've said look we're
cutting ties with the royal family
we want to forge ahead with this new way
of life they're going to continue to do
their work and in the next
three to six months we're going to see
some exciting
new developments of what archwell
intends to do and um
certainly we're going to have a new
little royal baby soon which is very
exciting as well announcing their baby
news without telling the palace
and confirmation of an interview with
oprah may have seemed
like the final straw but i'm told in
recent weeks the outcomes of discussions
had become very clear
there was no coming back as the queen
has shown many times before
she loves her family but nobody is
bigger than the institution
rhiannon mills sky news